if you do
weigh
um let's say the the
the taste of milk that's what you have
on one side and then the difference
between like
oat and
oat milk and normal milk to the
suffering of a cow that's those are on
your two sides what if the problem with
reducing your animal intake is actually
chronic health problems and then what
you have on one side is an increase in
chronic health problems
and then that's suffering
compared to the life of an animal
and chronic health problems like that's
a different story right
welcome to episode 157 of my podcast i'm
michaela peterson
in this episode i spoke with alex
o'connor alex is the founder of the
cosmic skeptic youtube channel and an
ethical vegan
he uses his channel to facilitate
philosophical and ethical debates that
range in topics but often focus on
animal rights advocacy and religion
alex is a recent graduate of oxford
where he studied philosophy and theology
the last time i saw alex the first time
we met in person was at the
beyond meat debate at oxford where i
spoke about why we shouldn't ban meat
altogether
alex was at the debate and i like him
quite a bit so i'm glad we could finally
speak
it was a fun episode i don't agree with
veganism i think the way forward is
through regenerative agriculture
but i think we covered some very
interesting topics and i think i'll have
alex back on to discuss religion as well
let me know what you guys think this
episode of the podcast was brought to
you by goldco a leader in the precious
metals industry
inflation is at its highest rate since
1980 and i don't think anyone really
knows how bad it's going to get
our times are kind of unprecedented with
a worldwide shutdown of the economy from
covid which probably wasn't the
brightest idea
we've diversified our family's portfolio
to include precious metals which have
been shown to be a good hedge against
inflation i had peter schiff on
my podcast in a previous episode that
convinced me gold was a pretty stable
idea
gold co has helped thousands of
americans protect over a billion dollars
in their retirement savings gold co is
an easy place to start
and has an a plus better business bureau
rating they're currently offering a
promotion that's pretty crazy it gives
qualifying new customers up to ten
thousand dollars in free silver
diversifying your portfolio is
definitely a good idea at the moment
visit
mplikesgold.com and they'll give you up
to ten thousand dollars in free silver
when you open a qualifying account
that's
mplikesgold.com tell them that i sent
you enjoy this episode
alex o'connor welcome to my podcast
michaela it's good to see you again if
not in person virtually it's
it's good to see that you're doing well
thank you very much i feel like this
podcast has been a long time coming so
it should be good it has it has yeah a
very long time i think the last time we
saw each other was
at oxford right
yes it was and i have a bit of a bone to
pick with you about that actually
because i remember not long after that
event um which anybody who has
seen or is familiar with with the both
of us might not know that i was there uh
because you were
you you were speaking and i was just
kind of there as a guest in my in my
fancy black tie and there was one
particular speaker on
uh the other side to you
who
it got kind of people were making a bit
of a song and dance out of this out of
this woman's speech and i found it quite
funny because i remember being in the
room
and i'm sure people will have seen this
because i'm pretty sure you took the the
clip and put it on your own channel
right
yeah yeah with some sort of inflammatory
title
yeah and uh i know your dad talked about
it too uh quite quite a bit about this
this crazed woman this crazed feminist
woman who is doing this ridiculous vegan
speech and i i must say it was a bit
fanciful
bit fanciful
a bit fanciful i'm gonna insert a clip
here and then we're going to see what
what people think about a bit fancy yeah
i i guess i'm i'm trying to be
diplomatic here because i did think it
was hilarious because of i was sort of
sat on this on this front bench and i
was directly opposite your dad and i
thought
like what watching this speech is is
funny enough like it was quite an
entertaining thing to do and i but i
thought of all the people to do this
speech in front of of all yeah i know on
planet earth it was just hilarious so i
sort of seeing him just like like
shriveling and it's like cringe and pain
yeah
but you know so there was this funny so
i remember sort of you and him both
posting about it a lot and and
i don't know i wondered if you were sort
of posting about it as if to say
hey look at this this wokeness or
whether you're posting it to say hey
look at this sort of veganism i didn't
know if it was more the more the
veganism part or more the woke part that
you're not trying to warn of
100 more the woke part however i do
think that there is an overlap now i
don't think you embody that overlap um
but i do think that there is an overlap
especially with people who are really
interested in like uh protecting the
climate veganism
like wokism i think there's an overlap
but what i was trying to portray with
her video was
was the woke part for sure i think most
of her like most of the language she
used had more to do with that than
veganism
yeah yeah it's actually one of the the
main things that i that i try to
uh promote whenever i'm talking about
veganism or just the ethics of animal
suffering more broadly is to try and
separate it from
[Music]
i want to say political connotations but
that's a little bit too broad but
there's this idea that to be a vegan you
have to
take up yoga and wear loose clothing and
grow out your hair and this kind of
thing um i i think we need more vegans
who wear suits we need more vegans who
are sort of culturally on the right
not not because
i think it's good to be culturally on
the right but just because i think it's
important to separate the issue of
animal exploitation as being bad
from
being a kind of fringe woke phenomenon
which is what at least veganism
certainly is uh at the moment uh which
is why i'm i'm glad that you're willing
to have me on to talk about this
because i know that the perception of
veganism is
pretty negative i mean the biggest
problem that the vegan community faces
is probably a pr problem um
and i guess i'm just trying to
contribute to
removing
that problem um
it's it's quite difficult to know why
exactly it is that it's connected in
that way i think it's got something to
do with the fact that
people on the left and people who are
part of the this this woke phenomenon
are certainly
um
more inclined to be in favor of radical
revolutionary thought it's something
that it sort of gives them something to
fight about and this is what a lot of
it's a lot of it's about and of course
veganism is a wonderful example of of
this because you have this huge problem
of animal exploitation and factory farms
that definitely need solving and so it
makes sense to me that this would this
would be like
you know music to the ears of people who
are wanting a social issue to
fight strongly for
but i resent to see that it's often
reduced to that that this sort of it's
intrinsically connected to this this
wokeness which wokeness itself has
become a bit of a meme it's not even
clear exactly what it what it means um
but i guess i'm trying to sort of move
the perception away from that and say
that no what veganism really is about at
least ethical veganism or the kind of
veganism that i would promote
is the rather simple proposition that if
we can avoid inflicting unnecessary
suffering then we should do so that's
what it breaks down to for me so you
know thanks for having me on to talk
about it i do appreciate it yeah no
problem at all um i think i think part
of the issue is a lot of people who are
pushing veganism from what i've seen
like the people with the viral videos
online i don't know if they're
interested in veganism to reduce animal
suffering or to make themselves appear
as if they're doing something virtuous
right like that's the main goal of their
veganism so i think what you're doing
it puts you in a different camp than
what a lot of people are doing and i
think that's maybe where the overlap
with wokeness is which is
there are
some
i wouldn't even call them woke but there
are some people a lot of people on the
left that are actually interested in
equality and reducing suffering really
and then there are people who are just
interested in it so that they appear
virtuous
yeah but then of course that's a problem
with
any ethical issue
it can be difficult to separate those
people who are doing it for the for the
sake of really caring and
those who don't but equally because you
know if you do something long enough um
especially if you make it sort of your
job so for for quite a while advocating
for veganism and making noise about
animal suffering was essentially all i
was doing all the time talking on
podcasts giving talks this kind of thing
and it gets to a point where
you're sort of talking very emotively
about the suffering of animals but
you're talking about it so so so much
that it's almost like you don't really
feel it anymore and
so you know i like to sort of take
breaks and make sure that i'm i'm
constantly rethinking what i'm saying
and not not being i guess dogmatic about
it um but i think you know sometimes you
might see people who
look as though they're just doing it for
the sake of it they don't really care
about animals they're just doing it
because they think it looks good or
something like that
but i think that that can actually often
be just
a result of the fact that these people
are talking about it so much that you
basically become insensitive to it
okay i can see that i mean i've had that
happen even just with
me going on other people's podcasts
talking about my health experience
even when i went to oxford and talked
about my health experience it's like at
a certain point i've talked about it so
much that
and which is good psychologically so
i've like desensitized myself to it so
it's not traumatizing anymore but it's
also it also means that the emotions
associated with it aren't like raw like
they were and it's just
yeah yeah i
i remember uh when you were in oxford
and we took a picture together and
posted it on instagram and i got quite a
lot of messages
from
my vegan followers and even my non-vegan
followers sort of being like why are you
hanging out with the antithesis of the
vegan movement because i'm not the
antithesis though that's the thing it's
like i stopped i had an issue with
animal suffering for my entire life i
stopped eating pork when i was like 14
because i figured you know pigs are the
most intelligent they probably suffer
the most and i don't have to eat that um
i've always thought meat was healthy and
i think that's probably because my
grandpa hunted so it was like in my
family
but
but i mean even since carnivore or the
lion diet i've tried to
be careful about where my animals are
from and i have enough money that it's
not difficult for me to source
um
meat from farms
that raise the animals
in like the best way i see possible if
you are going to end up killing an
animal at least not factory farming
right so
i'm definitely on board with the
reduce reduce suffering and i think that
that helps you know factory farming is
also
an issue for the environment
as well right and it's just like not
that's not a comfortable
way to live and if you watch like
anybody who watches videos of factory
farming it's like that's not good right
nothing about that looks good yeah it
seems like everybody knows this but but
it's worth bearing in mind that some
something like i i want to say over 95
percent of animal products consumed i'm
not sure about america i think it's
higher i think it's something like 98
um but the vast majority of animal
products consumed come from factory
farms of course if you ask people on the
street you know do do you eat meat or
something like this and they can tell
that you're sort of maybe
going to raise an ethical concern
they'll often say something like well
yeah but i try to make sure that i get
it from the best kind of sources i know
that there are people in the world who
who do do this there are a lot of people
but at the same time i find it quite a
mystery that pretty much anybody that i
speak to about this will say yeah i try
to make sure that my my meat and my
animal products come from from ethical
sources
and that makes up the vast majority of
people and yet
it is simultaneously the case that the
vast majority of our animal products are
coming from factory farms i'm not sure
that people are being
either totally honest or maybe they
don't quite understand the the breadth
of factory farming and the
the grasp that it has over our over our
food of course if you're really tracking
the food if you've got your own farm or
something like that then it's easy
enough but you know if you walk into a
supermarket or a restaurant or fast food
chain into a kfc into a starbucks or
something
this is all factory farmed and the real
strength of the vegan movement is
against factory farming right like my
the reason that i'm sort of like
getting up on a soapbox as it were and
trying to proselytize about this kind of
thing veganism as it's sometimes called
is really because of the plight of
animals and factory farms you know if we
were still doing farming how we were a
few hundred years ago it would still be
an interesting ethical problem to solve
it there'd still be especially if we
have alternatives available that'd be an
important ethical question as to whether
we have the right to breed animals into
existence and take their lives away from
them and inflict certain sufferings in
their life but it certainly wouldn't be
the the forefront of my campaigning it
wouldn't be the main thing that i spend
my time doing it's really about the
factory farming which is why i say when
people were surprised to to see i mean
even even if you were the antithesis of
vegan like to take a picture together i
mean it's it's
hardly the most incriminating thing in
the world but
i i got that impression just from
talking to you then as well that
at least ostensibly we're both
against let's say unnecessary animal
suffering that's what the vegan position
in my view essentially reduces to and
you're right to say that
there's an environmental problem as well
that's actually not something that i
talk about very much because i think
that more people are going yeah vegan
now for the environment rather than the
ethics which
sure it's kind of admirable but it seems
to me like it sort of misses the point
uh ethically it would be as if we were
sort of stood on a hill and we saw this
factory in the distance it was like a
puppy mill that was breeding and
torturing puppies and forcing them into
cages and disbudding them and this kind
of thing
and you said oh this is so terrible we
need to end this i said yeah you said i
mean just look at the fumes it's
submitting it it's so bad for the
environment
it's like okay you're not wrong you're
not incorrect about that but i feel like
you're sort of maybe missing the ethical
point here the real the real
motivating
factor of all of this for me is is the
suffering but look we have an animal
suffering problem in factory farming
which on its own in my view i've said
this a few times before on its own
is a good enough reason to abolish
factory farming and probably go vegan
there's an environmental case against
factory farming because they're just
absolutely disastrous to the environment
which again on its own the environmental
case would be good enough reason to
abolish factory farming there's also a
pandemic prevention case i did a tedx
talk about this that
while our governments were telling us to
keep us far apart from each other as
possible we're simultaneously cramming
tens of billions of disease-ridden
animals into these ridiculous ignoble
hell holes to share their diseases with
each other and just exponentially
increase the risk of them developing
into a zoonotic disease with the
potential to infect other human beings
so the pandemic prevention on its own
when you know when our governments say
they're doing everything they can to
prevent this kind of thing happening
again it's like give me a break as long
as factory farming is still on the scene
it's an absolute joke that on its own
is good enough reason to abolish factory
farming
antibiotic resistance most people know
that resistance is the issue
of the medical community but the
majority the majority of antibiotics
that are sold
are used on livestock
not human beings right and so this is
driving your antibiotic resistance so
what you have here and there's also like
health concerns but i think that's a bit
more technical but just take those four
right you've got the suffering case the
environmental case the antibiotics in
the case pandemic for engine case which
each on their own is enough reason to
abolish factory farming right but we
have all four of them all of them
together on one side of the scale and
then i ask people what's on the other
side of the scale for most people
it's a sausage roll
it's milk in your coffee
well i'd see that bacon in the morning
this is where we disagree and i think
this is uh this was brought up
with some of the people on the vegan
side for the for the oxford debate uh
one guy was talking about oh um you how
do you weigh pleasure how do you waste
suffering against the pleasure you
experience eating meat and what i would
argue is especially in in america um i
think the major cause behind chronic
disease is diet and i think that a
plant-based push is going to make people
sicker and i think
removing meat from people's diet i don't
think we understand the um repercussions
of doing that so it's funny because
everybody who's concerned about this is
concerned about suffering on some level
so
uh animal suffering right for people who
are more concerned about the climate i
think they're they're basically
concerned about human suffering right
because if the climate gets all screwed
up then eventually that leads to human
suffering and what i'm concerned about
is just human suffering and i know and
i'm biased from my experience and from
what i've seen for people who've gone
paleo and kind of gone back to ancestral
eating is
being chronically it like i would
i would stop the suffering of somebody
who's chronically ill
and i don't even i like animals don't
even cross my mind like that amount of
suffering compared to a human being
that's chronically ill and so i think
that's where
we might differ unless i'm potentially
again it requires a bit more digging for
for start you said that you only care
about human suffering um i i should i
don't only care that's not true right
that's what we can reduce like
regenerative farming and i've advertised
this quite a bit hopefully i've talked
about it on my podcast we should be
making a move towards regenerative
farming and the more people that buy
meat from regenerative farms the more
likely regenerative farms are to take
off but i would rather see a push
towards regenerative farming than
towards veganism because i think those
are going to have major health
repercussions that we can't foresee at
the moment or that we are foreseeing but
not attributing to less meat yes on an
animal suffering front a regenerative
system of farming is is infinitely
preferable to factory farming you're
still going to run into an ethical qualm
when it comes to taking lives that don't
need to be taken um i i guess i'm a bit
more relaxed than than most vegans and i
don't even like using the word vegan
because people are sometimes upset with
exactly how i how i um use the word how
i define it
or the situations in which i think it
would be permissible to eat animal
products a lot of people
have told me that
it's potentially misleading really i
just have a commitment to minimizing
animal suffering so
coming at this from an from a from an
ethics perspective more than a practical
one
i i quite simply just grant the
conditional right if it is the case that
this is going to minimize suffering then
that's the right thing to do so if it
turns out let's say that sort of um
hunting
is actually a better way
to procure our nutritional requirements
because of course we could eat plants
but you know plant production plant
agriculture requires killing animals too
and it's possible that in some
circumstances hunting an animal might
kill less animals and it might actually
be
less painful for that animal
like i don't know about the
practicalities of that i actually i
don't know but i'm just willing to just
grant easily that if it is actually the
case that that involves less animal
suffering then that is the thing to do
now most most people define veganism at
least the vegan society defines it as a
minimization or an exclusion to the
highest extent practicable of all forms
of animal exploitation um i like to use
the word animal suffering there um
and and
it means it's got a slightly strange
implication which is that if veganism is
just
excluding animal suffering to the
highest extent practicable then even if
you are killing an animal for food if
you're doing it in such a way that
genuinely minimizes to the highest
extent practicable or forms of animal
suffering or exploitation then it's not
just that you're permissibly breaking
veganism or something like you're doing
the vegan thing according to the ethical
definition because of course
vegans shouldn't be under the
the illusion that not responsible for
any animal suffering of course we are we
need to most people know about the
problem of crop deaths right like the
animals are being killed in the
production of plants of course
vastly more plants are currently being
used to feed a livestock and so the best
way to minimize even just crop deaths is
to eat the crops directly because it
takes less crops to feed a human than it
does to to to feed livestock but in
other words like if you think that
veganism means that you don't harm
animals in the production of your food
then
what are you eating exactly you're
probably going to be starving yourself
and so even for the for the for the
vegan who eats nothing but plants
we're still contributing to some animal
suffering we just recognize that by
eating the plants directly we're
contributing to a lot less so we already
grant the idea that to be vegan is just
to minimize animal suffering to the
highest extent that we can which means
that if there were a situation in which
the way to minimize the amount of animal
suffering was to go and you know shoot
the elk then go and shoot the elk and
call yourself a vegan for all i care i'm
just interested in the ethics of
minimizing suffering here
that was great i liked that
okay okay i brought you on to talk about
a few things
not just veganism that was good though i
liked that last bit a lot
i'm in agreement there i think yeah i
mean i think i think we agree more than
people think that that we do i mean your
condition is is different as well your
situation i mean to say because of the
the fact that
like
as far as i understand like the reason
why i mean it's it's funny your diet
will be more restrictive than mine is as
a oh my gosh yeah it's awful um which is
quite strange but
there's there's a world of difference
between
you sort of average joe who like eats
kfc because he thinks it's it tastes
nice and animals are here for us to to
kill bro and somebody who says look i
just actually need this to
survive and be healthy like these are
different justifications and embedded
into the definition of veganism is
practicability that's kind of the
operative word so like
of course if it were going to like when
somebody says um it's not healthy to be
vegan the vegan response is usually well
yes it is like look at these look at
these studies look at look at the the
scientific consensus or whatever like
vegans generally don't say something
like well i don't care if it's unhealthy
you have to do it anyway right they say
no it is healthy and that's why you have
an obligation to do it but the
implication of that the corollary is
that if it were not healthy if it were
genuinely not healthy and not
sustainable for you
then it would be permissible to to eat
animals and and that's a position that i
hold and i think is a position that's
embedded into the very definition of
veganism so
if you look at the definition of ethical
veganism look at what it's actually
about
it's a it's a lot more um it's a lot
more sort of inclusive and relaxed i
think
then might be represented by certain
vegan activists that you might see on
the street screaming about you know
drinking drinking milk under any
circumstances it's just about minimizing
suffering which most people are already
committed to
okay i like it now normally at the
beginning of each episode i ask people
who they are and what they do but we
just kind of got into it so so
if anyone hasn't figured it out by now
uh can you give a brief background about
who you are and what it is you do
um so i'm a i'm a vegan um
which it's actually amazing that i that
i haven't said that yet that's usually
it's not even how i introduce myself on
podcast it's just how i introduce myself
to anybody it's the first thing i say
before my name um my name is alex
o'connor um and i'm something of a
reluctant vegan actually i started life
on youtube making videos about the
philosophy of religion quite
embarrassing
embarrassingly really i started when i
was 16 17 something like that and so
some of the older material is just
embarrassingly poor but it's been
interesting to sort of be able to track
this philosophical change and growth so
i made videos about the philosophy of
religion which moved on to talking about
philosophy more broadly and then ethics
and then somebody well people kept kind
of asking me just as like a fringe issue
it was sort of like you know people
would ask me about
abortion or euthanasia or you know
capital punishment or veganism
and i thought you know i'll get around
to all of these and one day i finally
decided to sit down and read animal
liberation by peter singer which is to
this day the greatest philosophical
defense of the vegan position that
exists
was written in 1975
and
well philosophy is perennial the first
chapter it's it reads just as well today
and
i just remember thinking like i must be
missing something it was so so
straightforward
and so i made a video on my youtube
channel saying it was called a me
teacher's case for veganism and i said
look here are some arguments that i'm
considering i think these lead towards
towards the vegan position the vegan
philosophy
please for the love of god somebody talk
me out of it please i really like not
only do i want to change my mind for the
usual uh reason of just you know
intellectual consistency and
self-challenge but because i actually
really don't want this to be true i'm a
big fan of
kfc in particular um
i should say taste wise not morally uh
and nobody could and it's funny in that
video in the beginning i said in the
introduction oh don't worry everybody
this channel isn't becoming like a vegan
advocacy channel or something like that
i'm just making one video it's like
whoops
um but because nobody nobody can talk me
out of it and
so since then i've i've become something
of a sort of vegan youtuber speaker so
i'm invited to you know do talks and
podcasts and stuff and it's probably the
main thing now that i that i talk about
but it happened um potentially by
accident
when was that
that was 2019 april of 2019 so not sort
of that long ago actually uh but i mean
it feels like it's been it's been
forever and even in that time like my
position has wildly changed i mean it
started with this case of like
wow i had no idea about any of this i'm
just going to put a hold on all my
animal product consumption until i have
a bit more time to sort of work it all
out
and i've spoken to people from it's the
great thing about
being a being a podcaster having an
opportunity as you'll know to be able to
speak to so many wonderful interesting
people so i've been able to speak to
ethicists and uh you know dietitians and
i've been able to speak to psychologists
about the nature of pain in the brain
and how it works and this kind of thing
and um so my sort of position has been
consistently evolving but not once have
i come close to doubting the idea that
if we can avoid inflicting suffering
upon an animal
then we should do so um so the main
thing that that changed my mind on that
was uh an argument it was a it was a
sometimes called name the trait
which basically asks
there are a few ways to to word it but
you might want to ask something like
okay so 86 percent of
pigs or thereabouts in the uk who are
killed for slaughter are killed in gas
chambers so they're forced into metal
cages and lowered into chambers of
carbon dioxide
which um
is i mean you can watch it on youtube
and you can see it's a pretty painful
experience it also like acidifies the
liquids in their eyes and mouths okay so
this is this is pretty gross
now we would recognize
that if we force human beings into a gas
chamber that would be wrong in fact it
would be evocative of one of the worst
evils in human history and so the name
the trait argument can be surmised as
saying something like well how like a
pig and in what ways would that human
have to be
before you'd be okay with forcing it
into a gas chamber
so you name the trait so some people say
that well pigs are far less intelligent
than humans are and that's why we have
more moral worth so okay so the trait is
intelligent so let's take a human being
and let's lower their intelligence lower
their intelligence to the state of a
pigs let's give them like the tiniest
cognitive ability that you can imagine
can i force that human being into a gas
chamber off the back of that
no in fact you'd probably consider it
more evil to do that on the
justification that they have a low
intelligence okay so what if i gave the
human being like two new legs instead of
arms can i force them into a gas chamber
or definitely not what about if i made
their skin pink you know is is skin
color the relevant factor here well
definitely not okay so you can
essentially metamorphize this human
being into a pig
you can say well let's take this human
being give him four legs pink skin curly
tail intelligence level of a pig you
know experiences the world as a pig
suffers like a pig can i force this
human being into a gas chamber
and it seems like you never get to a
point where you say okay now we found
the justification now it's okay you can
put this being into a gas chamber but
you end up with a creature that's
identical
to the creature that we started with
which is the one that we force into gas
chambers and and not to not to win a war
not to buttress the economy not to build
infrastructure
because we think they taste nice
and
it just seemed ethically obvious to me
and so i thought i must be missing
something if this is still such a sort
of fringe minority view and so the past
few years of my life have been an
exercise and you know trying to get
people to talk me out of it
you should talk to uh diana rogers
because your your argument makes sense
if meat wasn't
i think necessary for health and i think
i think
i think that there's a lack of studies i
think that the studies are there and i
think diana rogers
who's a dietitian who does she wrote the
sacred cow and she's very interested in
regenerative agriculture
regenerative farming um but i i think
your argument would stand if it was just
about taste and if we could get all the
nutrients from a vegan diet but i think
that the long-term
i don't think long-term veganism helps
people and that's like mostly what i've
read online anecdotes
and then studies i also know that if you
put really really young kids on a vegan
diet that can be really harder in their
brain but if they eat animal products
it's not so i think i think your
argument would stand true and would be
impenetrable if
if meat wasn't such a health food
yes um and of course you're right that
the science is still very much in its
infancy and we must be careful okay like
this is really important if there is a
risk that this is actually
really not nutritionally adequate and
we're feeding it to children not really
knowing what we're doing and essentially
blinded by by what becomes ideology it
emerges from just a commitment to
minimizing animal suffering to an
allegiance to vague principles that are
sort of followed no matter what because
they're just sort of thought to be true
by our community
then we run into run into problems as i
say i'm sort of willing to grant this
this conditional claim that if it's not
actually healthy then not only is it
sort of morally permissible to not be a
vegan as it were but to
basically eat the
the minimal amount that we need to be
healthy and still call yourself a vegan
i mean we could probably do away with
the word it wouldn't be very helpful um
but of course it's worth bearing in mind
that
if it's the case that we think okay well
well meat is required for a for a
healthy diet or at least animal products
of a kind
uh sure but this of course doesn't give
us license to overindulge and it doesn't
give us license to uh procure these
products from factory farms i mean even
if it is the case that we need these
products in order to be healthy there is
simply no excuse none for what we're
currently doing to animals for what is
as i say essentially an over consumption
problem the numbers involved are just
like
unthinkably unthinkably huge especially
when you think about sea life which is
just the most
incredible i mean
yeah
sometimes i like to say i don't quite
know how to get it across though
sometimes i just say since i started
this sentence around 150 000 wild fish
have been caught from our oceans which
is roughly four seconds and in the space
of two minutes that would have risen to
3.6 million in two minutes right the
numbers involved are huge but also the
the lived experience of these animals
pigs forced into gas chambers cows being
separated from their calves you know you
everybody knows about this kind of stuff
um and so it's not good you should talk
to diana rogers like she makes a good
case i um i
i watched her there's also a documentary
she did it's called sacred cow and she
talks about how
um well
it seems like a good alternative if
we're to continue eating meat because i
like i'm in agreement with you that
factory farming well basically what i
what i tell people who watch my channel
is you know
and i give them a bit of more leeway i
say buy what you buy the best you can
afford so there's like companies like
white oak pastures that are doing a
really good job and like there are
companies out there that are doing
regenerative farming buy from those guys
if you can
um
a lot of the people who follow me have
autoimmune disorders are trying to get
out of them and are really sick and
they're like in bed and so for those
people i'm like do what you have to do
to survive and then once you get better
which is kind of what i did because i
didn't have very much money to begin
with and i just like
got off my medication got better and
then now well
i've been eating you know grass-fed
whatever for like three years but um
you should talk through her just to see
just to see if she can like
poke any holes yeah i i have i have come
come across her work i may have read the
book actually or at least i probably own
a copy somewhere at the very least um
but yeah you're quite right there's a
one one of the pr problems that veganism
has is is one of being quite
unempathetic for a movement that's
supposed to be grounded in empathy i
think it's worth remembering this
when when i say that
veganism is about minimizing animal
suffering to the highest extent
practicable people think about okay so
if you're
um if you're an inuit living in northern
canada and it's genuinely really
expensive to to import vegetables okay
fine you know eat the meat because you
can't afford it but i think we need to
be a bit broader in what we encompass in
terms of practicability so i like to
encompass things like for instance you
know sometimes i get messages from from
kids who say like i really want to try
this veganism thing or at least sort of
minimize my diet but but i live at home
and and my mum cooks my meals for me and
she she doesn't want to hear it and
they're really stressed out they're like
but i don't i don't know what to do like
i can't refuse to eat this stuff and
i'm just like
relax like it's okay like this is the
kind of thing that i think is included
in practicability like sure okay
technically you could like you know say
screw your mom and you know steal some
money and go down to the shop and buy
your own food or whatever but like no i
think it's it's fine like you can talk
to her
about it over the dinner table and say
why you're not particularly comfortable
with it and then maybe it will get her
to change the cooking a little bit but
it's certainly not unethical to eat that
food right and so the practicability
requirement
i think should be considered quite
broadly and so it would include things
like living at home with your parents it
would certainly include things like
eating disorders definitely things like
autoimmune diseases especially if as you
say you're sort of bedridden and your
life is falling to bits like
that's pretty much the definition of
impracticability which i like to remind
people is embedded into the definition
of veganism so
it's all about empathy and we need to
remember that of course humans are
animals just like any other and so we
need to be empathetic to those
too
and understand that people will put
their health interests first um
so this is but this is the interesting
thing and why i thought it would be
interesting to talk to you because i
think that we
at least on the sort of philosophical
principles that say
are roughly in alignment i think our
different life experiences have have
probably shaped
how we think about the practicability of
eating meat i mean living in a city like
oxford it's
the easiest thing in the world to pop
down to the supermarket and buy meat
alternatives and i don't have any
serious allergies or anything like that
so you know
it's sort of easy enough for me to say
you know everybody stop eating meat
right but
as i talk to more people and begin to
understand that not everybody's in such
a comfortable position it's quite
edifying and leads me to
to when i speak about veganism try to be
a bit broader in terms of uh what might
be counted in terms of the
practicability requirement if you see
what i'm saying interesting
okay that's cool
i'm always i'm always uh surprised when
i talk to
vegans at how
like my my immune system is nuts right
my
i shouldn't be alive like things
something out there doesn't want me
alive i'm allergic to everything in ways
that's just
shocking so when i talk to people or
even when i see like other meat eaters
or just people eating like bread and
things
and looking like normal people like how
is that possible like how can i be
so different even my brother it's like
he'll go out and have a piece of pizza
and i was like if i had a piece of pizza
i think i would die
like like how
is it that different between people
sometimes but it's the thing i mean i i
can't imagine uh
having an experience like that having to
be so so careful and and
it's like um
you know like it reminds me of people
who have like serious nut allergies and
the thought of you know sometimes yeah
sat on a plane or something i have a nut
allergy too really i don't have a nut i
don't have a nut allergy like if someone
ate a nut beside yeah i would die but i
um i can't eat nuts without i had an
epipen for a long time like it's just
just stupid allergies yeah and i i think
about it and i just realized like i i
don't even know what it would be like to
have to think every time you get on a on
a bus or a plane or something like what
if somebody opens a packet of nuts and
my life isn't dangerous like it's crazy
right and
and
it's just it's incredibly important to
sort of be a bit human about this this
kind of thing because we get a bit lost
in the in the in the abstract philosophy
or in the the
the ideology and the the debate um but
this is really just about
as ethics always has been historically
it's about sort of
how human beings can live the best kind
of life um i just like to remind people
that if you're committed to a vague
notion of minimizing suffering then
the position boils down to something
like whenever you have the opportunity
to
uh let's say prevent or
um you know not inflict
suffering to animals take it
and that's it i mean if you don't have
that opportunity if that opportunity
isn't available to you then fine but as
long as it is i'm just recommending that
that's the course of action that people
should take and people are already on
board with this in in principle
um
but
in practice like you walk into a shop
and if you don't have
serious allergies and i recognize that
your audience is going to be
disproportionately different in this
respect but there'll be some people
listening who have no serious allergies
who have pretty good access to to all
kinds of foods in the supermarket and
live in a city where it's actually you
know not going to be more or less
expensive
you walk into that shop and
you know you go into starbucks
and you order a latte
and what are you paying for are you
paying for a cow to be forcibly
impregnated separated from the calf that
calf might be bolt gunned in the head
turned into veal or raised to go through
a similar cycle of exploitation the
dairy cow will you know go through this
this this cycle before being sold to a
slaughterhouse uh to be to be killed
because the dairy and the meat industry
are pretty tied up in this way where i
mean if it's an islamic slaughterhouse
the last thing it will hear is bismillah
and the sound of its own blood gushing
to the floor okay walk into the same
starbucks and add one word
i'll have an oat latte
i'll have an almond latte i'll have a
soy latte have hazelnut latte one of the
myriad options now available to us
and none of this happens on your dime
you're not paying for this anymore
and
a lot of people say like what we're
weighing up is like the the life of a
cow and it's and it's suffering and you
know i don't like to anthropomorphize
when i talk about
calves being separated from their
mothers i'm not trying to be cutesy like
the maternal bond that animals have is
something very much pre-human and
certainly sort of pre-rational
you can watch these these sadistic
videos it's almost comic there are these
technologies invented like a like a
truck or a quad bike with a with a cage
and an open door on the side of it and
they drive around and they sort of scoop
up the calf and drive her away and you
can watch these these mother cows
chasing after their children in
confusion
um
and people say that we're like weighing
this up the suffering of the the animal
versus like the the taste of milk or
something or the convenience of milk and
it's not even that it's not
because
what it really is is like the life of an
animal on one side of the scale and then
you have the the taste pleasure and the
convenience whatever
minus what you can get from a vegan
alternative and it's the leftover
slither that we weigh up against the
life of the animal so even if you know
oat milk doesn't taste quite as nice as
cow's milk which i i don't know if it
does it's a preferential thing but let's
say it's like 80 percent as nice so you
say it really isn't as nice it's like
okay you're not weighing up a cow's life
versus the taste of milk you're weighing
up a cow's life versus like 20 percent
of the taste pleasure that you get from
milk because the other 80 could have
been gotten from oat milk if you see
what i'm saying so it's it's pretty um
it's worse than people think uh in in
well that i like get where you're coming
from there but if my theory is correct
and that people can't be healthy without
animal products and i'm actually putting
dairy in a different category because
i can't tolerate dairy without really
bad
getting really bad arthritis and malt
like a multitude of issues so i don't
eat dairy or eggs
um they both caused issues but
if you do
weigh
um let's say the the
the taste of milk that's what you have
on one side and then the difference
between like
oat and
oat milk and normal milk to the
suffering of a cow that's those are on
your two sides what if the problem with
reducing your animal intake is actually
chronic health problems and then what
you have on one side is an increase in
chronic health problems
and then that's suffering
compared to the life of an animal
and chronic health problems like that
that's a different story right but i
mean it's not even it's not that useful
at the moment to have a conversation
about that because we need more data i
think part of the reason i've been
fighting back against um
kind of what i've called the vegan
ideology is because my concern is we
have these
people who are implementing agendas in
major cities those are doing like
meatless monday and things without the
proper
scientific background so we don't have
proper studies on these things now we
have studies like oh an increase in meat
increases your risk of i don't know
everything right like there's there's
any study out there that you can say it
increases your risk of heart disease or
etc
most of those studies aren't done
isolating meat they're done combining
everything else you eat with meat so the
bun the pop like everything and it would
make me feel a lot better if people who
are implementing
um
veganism in major cities and saying you
have to reduce the amount of meat you
eat even what's been happening in the
netherlands recently was taking away
kind of farmer's land saying you need to
produce less nitrogen
and that means you can't
you can't farm cows anymore it would
make me feel a lot better if i didn't
feel like there weren't
studies
being done as well it's like this issue
with chronic disease in north america
it's like killing people and reducing
the life expectancy of people and if
that has to do with diet and that has to
do with animal products and we're
pushing a vegan agenda to minimize
animal suffering and to minimize climate
change without looking at that part we
are in for a world of pain
in like 10 years
yes i mean but potentially um i i
imagine you probably receive similar
concerns about the the carnivore diet um
about its potential health implications
and that that you know there are sort of
maybe like there's sort of a bit of data
on this sort of healthy but it's 100 but
it's potentially sort of disastrous in
the in the i mean i don't know actually
about the sort of long-term if there's
been much research into the long-term
effectiveness there hasn't been any
which is the issue like this the
carnivore diet is ridiculously new and
the anecdotal reports are insane like
you have people who lost a bunch of
weight are off all of their medications
and have a disease that was incurable in
remission which doesn't happen right you
can't do that there are some people you
know you hear anecdotes with people who
go on the vegan diet too
and they're suddenly in remission and
yes i know
and i think that there's a reason for
that i think that if you
reduce the amount of dairy you're eating
or eliminate dairy and eliminate eggs i
think that those can cause a lot of
health issues for people and if you
eliminate processed foods that can make
you a lot healthier right off the bat
and that can all happen with a vegan
diet right and that's something
everybody should be doing regardless of
what diet they're on this episode is
sponsored by nordvpn if you've followed
the show for a while then you have
probably heard me complain about canada
and complain about canadian netflix
if you americans don't know
netflix and canada is bad
i mean netflix has been kind of
bad in america recently too but i
suppose at least it has variety i used
nordvpn to watch the best shows on
netflix anywhere in the world
from canada now that i live in good old
florida i don't have that issue anymore
but i still like to safeguard my online
activity nordvpn uses state-of-the-art
encryption that keeps you safe from
third parties who want to watch your
online activity it also protects you
from hackers malware and other malicious
threats that exist all over the internet
nordvpn's virtual private network uses
encrypted connections to guarantee your
online privacy
with their global coverage using 5300
servers around the world nordvpn doesn't
buffer or crash like other vpns
better safe than sorry with all the
weirdness in the world right now nordvpn
protects you from anyone knowing what
websites you've been visiting and i
think given the political atmosphere
right now it's worth doing just in case
grab your exclusive nordvpn deal by
going to
nordvpn.com
tmpp
to get a huge discount off your nord vpn
plan plus four months for free it's
completely risk-free with nord's 30-day
money-back guarantee sign up for nordvpn
and enjoy the rest of this episode
uh yes i mean
that's that's the funny thing about it
especially if you go vegan for sort of
health reasons or let's say
health reasons because you haven't been
particularly healthy before or ethical
reasons because you're not that
interested in health if you're eating an
average american diet then of course
when you eat a well-planned vegan diet
you're going to feel healthier and so
people often report sort of these crazy
energy boosts they feel cleaner they
feel healthier they're losing weight
this kind of thing
for myself i kind of
i
feel i want to say sort of roughly the
same i don't think it sort of makes it a
huge um
a huge difference either way but
yeah we we have to be we have to be
careful i think of course
to be a healthy vegan is going to be
more difficult than being a healthy meat
eater at least in terms of
sufficiently healthy so
if you sort of just eat vague animal
products if you just like eat some
chicken eggs few vegetables this kind of
thing like you're not going to be in in
great nutritional shape but you'll be
okay
if you take a similar approach as a
vegan and you just sort of like eat
whatever you just have like a vegan
cheese sandwich and
and some pasta
you're going to be in a lot more trouble
and so
while you know as far as i'm aware it is
possible certainly for adults and and a
lot of dietetic associations across the
world are saying that it's uh you can
get all the nutrients required for a
healthy living at all stages of life be
right like we should be skeptical of
these things we and we need to
especially when it comes to raising
children on these diets we want to be
sure right we don't want to be sort of
like well this this dietetic association
seems to think it's fine so let's go
ahead and do it it's like let's really
do some research here but just like the
research into the carnival diet which
you say is like brand new i mean
yeah it's science the vegan stuff is
still in its infancy too like this is
this is all fairly new so we do need to
be careful but equally
a lot of the time if
if you pay attention to what it is that
went wrong with people
on vegan diets it's something that could
at least in principle have been
avoided but as i say like the thing that
i really like to stress is that is i've
said a few times now is this conditional
claim that if it is actually unhealthy
then i think it's permissible right but
as i say
i would still be committed to minimizing
our intake and certainly from um
completely eliminating our intake when
it comes to factory farms
okay because i mean the factory farming
problem is is partly an over consumption
thing too right like if you
if you think to yourself well this
stuff's maybe wrong
and so everybody starts sort of
minimizing their intake let's say you
really do need meat to be healthy or
something like this one of the reasons
why factory farming exists is because of
the the amount of animal products that
people are eating it's just like not
sustainable to have apparently
apparently according to this diana
rogers character
apparently if everybody switched to
regenerative farming and there was no
factory farming the output
would be similar which i find
difficult to believe given how many
animals are in factory farms but i mean
i i've asked
them the people who wrote that book the
same question which was okay switching
to regenerative farming is all good but
say people do need meat for health and
say we need the same amount of meat
we're producing can you do that with
regenerative farming and she thought we
could and part of the reason we could do
that is because you can put animals like
goats and things
on mountainous areas where nothing else
can grow anyway and they can still
survive right so you can still be eating
plants on like rocky terrain where you
wouldn't be able to have other things so
apparently yeah but then i mean it would
still be the same but we're talking
about
somewhere between 80 and 100 billion
land animals alone
every single year i'm saying
i would say that it's certainly possible
that
especially if people start eating more
healthily and become more aware of their
diets and
minimizing their meat intake or
something like this that a global
regenerative system of agriculture would
be enough to sustain healthy living for
everybody
but to say that we'd get the same output
i don't know i'm not sure i'll have to
yeah maybe we need to
i want to ask you about oh my gosh it's
been an hour already okay
we might have to have another podcast
because i wanted to do
i wanted to ask you about your your
atheism beliefs and get into that but
that could be let's just leave that for
the next one because that could be an
entire thing on its own
um perhaps at some
point
we should have maybe i'll watch the
video again the sacred cow video because
i was surprised about
like what she claimed in it but it was
pretty interesting and maybe we could
have a conversation about that again to
see
if there's common ground there i i think
that there's a lot of overlap between
how you're thinking and how i'm thinking
and i think it all kind of chalks up to
you know if you could do a vegan diet
and
be equally as healthy even if it's more
difficult to achieve that like but if
you're careful and you can be equally as
healthy then i don't see anything wrong
with it the only reason that i see
something wrong with it is because i
believe that you're missing key
nutrients and that
and i think the only way to like rectify
that position
are to have more studies and like
properly done studies so you talked
about evidence for the carnivore diet
the only thing that we have at the
moment for the carnivore diet is a study
that was done
basically on self-reported symptoms from
people and so that's going to skew
towards people who are already feeling
better and like anybody in the
scientific community would just laugh at
that study however
it's enough those aren't that's like 3
000 anecdotes of people saying i was
really chronically ill and now i'm not
at all and that should be enough for
somebody in the scientific community to
say hey why don't we do
a controlled study like we need to do a
controlled study it's not that difficult
you take some people who are have
autoimmune disorders you monitor their
diet for six months and then see what
happens it just needs to happen right
and then at least we could have a
conversation about oh you know wow there
was overwhelming success this needs to
be taken seriously or oh no this is a
one-off but i like i don't see any
i don't know what to do without more
data
yes it's it's pretty difficult to know
but i don't think we need
really any data to know that factory
farming needs to come to an end um now
we have data for that too yeah we
actually we do like even just the um
what it does to the environment factory
yes of course but you know
you need only an antibiotic resistance
that enough like you said that alone
could be
that could be so bad for everybody on
the planet that we we need to avoid that
at all costs right yeah this well this
is why the copper pandemic
can sort of serve as a wake-up call as
people often like to to
leak from a lab
from a lab people have actually
misunderstood the point that i make when
it comes to kobe particularly because of
course covert is at least you know
it's thought a zoonotic disease um kind
of doesn't really matter i mean i i i
would certainly not claim that that
this covered pandemic came from factory
farming like that's definitely not the
case uh but we can say that like but the
next one will right we can we can say
if we look at something like covert and
look at how quickly we can just
completely debilitate our entire
population
and then we think okay how can we stop
this kind of thing happening again
regardless of
where these diseases have come from in
the past
if if we're taking disease-ridden
animals and we're forcing them into
close proximity in tiny cages and then
shipping them around the world to share
diseases with each other
the chances of a zoonotic disease
developing
is being exponentially increased and so
even if the last pandemic didn't come
from factory farming it's very likely
that the next one that the next one will
um but of course all of this by the way
all of this about the the animal
suffering and the gas chambers and the
disc budding and i haven't talked about
the experience of pigs and factory farms
which i think are the worst um well it's
not it's not the worst but pigs for some
reason for me have always been the
most easy to empathize with maybe due to
their intelligence similarity to dogs
whatever but like for example um
piglets who who are born on factory
farms
if they're too sick to be profitable and
this is often after having their teeth
yanked out and their tails cut off
without anaesthetic which by the way why
would they do that why would they yank
teeth out and cut the tails off piglets
when they're born that's because as the
pigs are kept in close proximity later
in life they start to basically go
insane and then start cannibalizing each
other out of frustration and hunger
and so they often do that by biting each
other's tails
at first and so they take out the teeth
and get rid of the tails but okay if
these if these piglets are too sick to
be profitable
then what happens to them well they'll
be killed most people can probably work
that out but how are they killed
well the most well one of the most
common methods is a method that's
colloquially known as thumping it's
blunt force trauma it's where the pigs
are literally just taken by their hind
legs these piglets and have their skulls
repeatedly smashed into the concrete
until they die
um
of course you can watch footage of this
and it seems when you see this kind of
stuff that it's like you know rogue
farmers picking up animals and smashing
their skulls into the pavement but this
method of caving in a piglet's skull
against the pavement is officially
approved by both red tractor and the
rspca which are kind of the animal
welfare governing bodies in the uk when
it comes to farm by the way the same
rspca that recently confiscated the
footballer curt zuma's pet cat because
footage emerged of him kicking it across
the kitchen for a laugh and filming it
and put it on snapchat they went and
confiscated that cat but they officially
approve as a method of slaughter for
piglets who could be kept alive but are
just too sick to be profitable to take
them by the hind legs and cave in their
skulls against the pavement
this this is this is obviously insanity
but what i wanted to say was that all of
this stuff that i'm talking about
is if the farmers are abiding by the law
right these are all legally approved
practices except i think um the the the
tail docking and the teeth um i think is
illegal in the uk at least but you know
farmers still do it but that's that's my
point is that like
sans that everything else i've talked
about everything is
legal this is this is industry standard
practice
and yet every single time we send hidden
cameras into factory farms we find that
farmers are routinely breaking even the
most sort of basic and
ridiculous uh legal guidelines that are
in place already so all of this this
horror and and moral embarrassment is
already occurring even if they're
following the law and then factor in the
fact that fact factor in the case or the
consideration that
in in a great many cases they're not and
the problem gets only worse there was a
there was a farm in
i think it was aberdeenshire i'll i'll
check that and make sure that's correct
cause i can't remember which farm it was
um that recently it was a red tractor
approved farm
which
uh was was discovered by sort of
undercover investigators to be thumping
piglets uh to death by caving in their
skulls against the
bars of the cages that their own mothers
were being kept in
this kind of stuff
is
crazy and so when people say to me kind
of like yeah you know i try to make sure
my meat comes from from a good source
it's like do you are we are we actually
on board about this because when i ask
people what do you think about this kind
of treatment of animals they say oh
that's horrible that's terrible it's
like well let's make some noise about it
then right let's stop buying factory
farmed animal products let's engage in
protests
what wouldn't the right way to encourage
people to stop eating factory farm to
give them alternatives rather than
saying just stop
like wouldn't that be a better even just
sales like sales of trying to stop
factory farming if i was going to market
that idea what i would do is hey
hey look at what's happening here this
is bad but look at this farm and what
they do it's only a little bit more you
can order it from this place it's only a
little bit more and you get to reduce
this amount of suffering and hey
it's carbon negative
isn't that a better cell than like just
stop it's definitely a better cell in
that i actually think this is this is
maybe what we're going to
begin to see happening as veganism grows
in popularity the response
there's likely
going to be cropping up at least when it
becomes significantly um
economically viable because there are
enough people who are willing to sort of
go vegan you'll have companies cropping
up saying like hey all of the problems
that the vegans are raising about this
horrible treatment that they tell you
about and the footage they show you
here's our farm we don't do any of that
we keep the calves with the mothers and
we when they produce their milk all this
kind of stuff and and this is fine and
definitely as you say that's definitely
going to sell better than only eat
plants so it's definitely going to be
more likely to convince people to stop
eating meat
and also it is genuinely obviously
infinitely preferable to to factory
farming
of course
when you start
really engaging in animal ethics and
sort of vegan activism and animal ethics
i see as two totally different spheres
vegan activism is about as you say
what's going to get people to stop
eating meat what's going to sort of
bring down factory farming this kind of
thing whereas animal ethics is like this
interesting academic study into the the
nature of pain and what morally matters
once you sort of engage in that for long
enough you realize that there are
arguments to say that even if we're not
factory farming animals there might be
good reason not to be killing them
unnecessarily and so you might be
committed ethically to the view that you
know farms that
uh that aren't factory farms that that
produce so-called sort of ethically
produced meat um
are still unethical they're still as
long as you've got sort of plant-based
alternatives available to you uh but as
i said earlier that would become
become
almost like more pedantic it would be
kind of like yeah like
because sort of taking the life of an
animal without its consent is is wrong
we should probably be eating plants
instead but it wouldn't be this like
huge obvious moral emergency that
factory farming is so
yes i agree with you that it that it
sells better but it's it's difficult for
somebody who's ethically committed to
the view that
essentially exploiting animals is always
wrong to advocate for that right people
have often compared it to other ethical
issues um you know talking about how
they want no cages rather than bigger
cages this kind of thing it's like if
you advocate for incremental steps you
seem to sort of be
legitimizing um
legitimizing the process i mean you can
imagine imagine somebody talking about
like abortion imagine like a pro-life
activist and there was some way to sort
of make you know abortions
slightly less painful for the for the
fetuses or something you know presuming
that the fetus is a level where it can
feel pain and we say we've developed
this technology where
as as they're being killed they feel
like 50 less pain or something like that
but they're still in pain and the
pro-life will probably say no this is
still horribly immoral and i said to
them well but don't you recognize that
this would be a better cell if you told
somebody who was you know who wanted to
have an abortion like
hey if you use this procedure you know
that the child's going to feel less pain
they're going to say yes and they're
going to be far more likely to say yes
to that than they are to just bringing
the baby to full term i think the
pro-lifer would still have a hard time
sort of advocating for this technology
for the technology that sort of fifty
percent reduces the pain involved in
abortion or something like that do you
see what i'm saying yeah oh yeah it
would be it would be important it would
be impossible to do that so for someone
in my position who sort of does deeply
care about animal suffering um
more broadly than just factory farming
it's still troublesome to me the idea of
animals being bred and confined and
killed
but it's it's way way better than
factory farming so i i'd celebrate a
move from factory farming to more
traditional forms of agriculture
but i still think that i would be
in the camp of arguing that plant-based
agriculture is the way to go or at least
cultivated meat which is the the next
big sort of exciting
development in the in the conversation
which is if we can produce
sort of you know
essentially biologically the same matter
without causing any animal suffering
then the problem essentially just
disappears
yeah well if that's a possibility and it
is just meat but it's from a lab than
hooray but i feel like that sounds like
that's
yeah but it doesn't exist not really no
yeah i mean you can you can probably buy
like a lab-grown burger for like half a
million dollars or something at the
moment because the technology is there
but this is how all technologies start
and so to answer your question because
it's a bit of a long-winded
answer and i don't want to be seen like
i'm avoiding uh the question you said
well isn't like sure like advocating for
veganism is is great in all to stop
factory farming but it wouldn't actually
just be more effective
to advocate for but it wouldn't just be
it wouldn't it wouldn't just be more
effective it would also mitigate the
risk that
long-term veganism isn't healthy for
people and that and it's not just that i
think that i and i do believe this i
think if you'd gone back
say
say to the 1940s this is just a theory
here but i feel like if you've gone back
to the 1940s and you put somebody on a
vegan diet it's possible that they could
do it properly to be healthy
longer term like i'm willing to go that
far i think the amount of chronic
illness we have now and how sick the
average person is like the um percentage
of people with autoimmunity it's
skyrocketed that mental disorder is
obesity right it's bad right now i think
the average person right now is sick
and
that's why we're seeing such restrictive
diets work for people like i don't think
the carnivore diet
there are there were some anecdotes of
people in like the 1910s on a carnivore
diet they went to visit um inuits and
then
they already ate like that so
set aside i don't think
you'd see so many people on a carnivore
diet 60 or 70 years ago when people
didn't have these chronic diseases i
don't think my diseases would like
existed exactly back then but i think if
you're dealing with people now uh
pushing for regenerative farming also
mitigates the issue that we could
potentially be pushing a diet that's
going to increase chronic disease which
i think it might and at least i think we
need more studies to prove that it
doesn't yeah i understand that concern
and i think
a lot of vegans would be quick to
dismiss it with
reference to
as i say like dietetic association
saying that veganism is healthy it's
it's like we
need to take this stuff very seriously
you know scientific communities being
like being like yeah we've done some
studies and it seems pretty safe to be
doing this to our children it's like we
need to be we need to be really sure
about this stuff so so
although i'm i'm i guess i'm pretty
optimistic about the idea of a
plant-based diet being
nutritionally adequate
i wouldn't want to dismiss those
concerns and i would like to sort of
amplify that i uh care about them too
uh but
there's kind of a way of of avoiding
both problems which would be cultivated
lab grown me this is like if there was
one thing that
we could sort of all focus on as what's
actually
in reality probably going to have the
biggest effect it might be lab grown
meat because you still get the animal
products that you want to eat you you
still avoid the sort of health concerns
that you're talking about but also you
now don't actually have to kill any
animals at all and so even if we're sort
of not sure what we think ethically
about taking the lives of animals if
they've had a net positive existence
which i'm actually quite sympathetic to
the view that if they genuinely have a
net positive existence and that
existence is
parasitic on the idea that they will be
killed eventually that might actually be
good for the animal probably is good for
the animal um regenerative farming may
be which depending on the farm
interestingly isn't quite the same thing
as saying that you have the right to
kill them i mean it might be the case
that it is actually better for the
animal to bring them into existence and
then kill them but as jeff mcmahon who
was at the event in oxford pointed out
in in a
a
pretty wonderful essay
on
the eating of animal products even if it
were the case that this animal wouldn't
exist
if we didn't plan to kill it
and it was better for the animal to
exist and then be killed once it exists
it's still arguable that you don't have
the right to take its life because now
that it exists there's like a it's like
an interest that you're upsetting by
killing it it's a bit of a bit of an
sort of sidetrack but what i was going
to say is that lab grown meat might
solve all this problem um and so i think
that if we could sort of invest a lot
more time and energy into lab-grown meat
we'd we'd be uh we'd be on the right
track but as you say it's quite a long
way off so we're sort of figuring out
what to do in the meantime but that's
kind of how i see it given the advent of
this technology and how revolutionary it
could be
for me it's kind of a case of well what
do we do in the meantime you know for
the next i don't know a few decades or
however long it's going to take might
take longer than that who knows you know
how do we um how do we manage ourselves
and until then
but i think that would probably be the
best option but i've said before um in
some podcasts or interview or something
that
although i do think that
because you were asking about sort of
what's actually going to be the most
effective method of getting people to
change something like that's going to be
the answer but i've said before that i
do pity the people who will have to
explain to their grandchildren right
when when they sort of their
grandchildren are saying to them
you knew about factory farming yeah you
knew about the mistreatment of animals
that was going on in there you knew that
there were healthy alternatives from
plant-based agriculture and even you
know regenerative agricultural
alternatives that you may have had
access to they go yeah sure and they say
so why
why were you still eating animal
products and you have to explain to them
that until lab-grown meat came about you
know you just it just wasn't the same
you know i just couldn't quite stomach
that that chickpea burger or something
like that although i do think um it is
the case in other words in reality that
most people will in fact change their
diets based on something like lab grown
meat rather than an ethical case
it's going to be a pretty awkward
conversation when they have to explain
that that's what it took because the
ethical case wasn't enough for them
unless it has health implications of
course yeah so so for those people would
be um the people who are eating animal
products just because they taste nice
which i would wager and i don't exactly
have a statistic to back this up but i i
would i would suspect that the majority
of people who are eating animal products
are eating them
i want to say how can i word this the
majority of instances in which somebody
eats an animal product will be based on
taste pleasure
but maybe because maybe the reason
people actually like the taste is
because we've grown accustomed to it
because it's healthy
yeah i know that that would be no
surprise to me in fact like that
evolutionarily makes sense right like
it's it's
the reason why certain things are
pleasurable to us you know
by and large is because they're actually
beneficial to our survival um but of
course
like the the whole process of ethics
like what is ethics what is ethical
progress well it's sort of
overcoming our naturalistic animalistic
impulses to act in accordance with what
we think is right and moral rather than
what our sort of
sensory uh
pleasure inputs tell us that we
immediately want you know it's kind of
what ethics is it's overcoming that kind
of thing that's true i do think that
people
fall into the mistake of ignoring
what their body tells them is right
though by listening to what their brain
tells them is right i think that's
that's an issue that our society is
seeing and i think probably going back
to what you feel is right is probably a
good way to be ethical kind of a hippie
way to be ethical maybe and it doesn't
necessarily work like cocaine might feel
good it doesn't mean that it's ethical
or it's going to be good for you but you
kind of know
when you're doing that kind of thing
that it's not a good idea right and the
hedonistic stuff isn't a good idea i
don't know if you get that from you
might get that from kfc
that's like that's not going to make
anybody feel good that's purely taste
and that that's hedonism and there's
nothing healthy about that that's just
bad
and so when i talk about these people
who will have to explain this to their
grandchildren or people who are just
eating based on taste pleasure and you
come along and say what about all the
people that are that are doing this for
really like uh for the sake of their
health because they need to it's like
yeah okay i agree that that's a
different story but like
i'm talking there to the people who are
sort of going to kfc you know if you go
into kfc and see the people sort of
queuing up and and these are like some
of the most popular producers of animal
products your mcdonald's and your kfc's
and this kind of thing so i do think
that
it is a separate ethical question or at
least an adapted ethical question when
somebody is eating animal products
because they genuinely need to but of
course if they genuinely need to then
the definition of veganism accounts for
this but if you look at the majority of
animal products that are being sold if
you walk into a mcdonald's and i was
saying all of this kind of stuff i walk
into a mcdonald's and say you're all
going to have to explain this to your
grandchildren you know that there's a
vegan alternative just down the road and
now even in mcdonald's you can get a
vegan alternative but you won't do so um
i think that that point stands but yes i
mean the one thing that i wanted to
emphasize and again why i thought it was
important to talk to you
and reach an audience like yours who as
you say will disproportionately be at
least knowledgeable about uh
health concerns as related to
animal products and and the necessity of
eating meat in this kind of thing is
that
yeah i can't speak for vegans broadly
but certainly the ethical veganism that
i promote is the kind that says that if
you actually
need animal products to be healthy then
not only can you break your veganism but
you can eat animal products and still
call yourself a vegan although i
wouldn't do if i were you because it
comes with a lot of social baggage
okay alex that was great um i have to go
but i would like to have another
conversation um because you do you do a
lot
yeah you can try to talk me out of
christianity
the god thing yeah yeah
recently let's do that next okay
for sure if people want to follow you
online where should they go
uh well my i don't think i even said
earlier that my my online pseudonym is
cosmic skeptic as i said i made this
account when i was like 16. um
so it's quite a unique name so basically
anywhere slash cosmic skeptic twitter
youtube youtube's the main one tiktok
now also regrettably but i'm there too
so anything forward slash cosmic skeptic
will take you there
okay thank you again that was fun of
course